public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la campagne du second tour connaît une
accélération brutale 1 ces dernières
heures avec ce duel surprise à amiens
entre marine le pen et emmanuel macron
tous deux sur place et puis il ya eu
également tout à l'heure l'annnonce du
vote macron par nicolas sarkozy et dans
ce contexte nous recevons le
vice-président du front national bonsoir
fait rien philippe courard et merci
d'être avec nous pour ce rendez-vous de
public sénat avec les échos radio
classique et l' agence france-presse
vous répondrez à trois grandes questions
d'abord quel est donc votre stratégie
pour le second tour 1 est ce imposer le
tempo qu'on enlève et où donc
aujourd'hui à l'usiné nouvelle poule
damien et se défier emmanuel macron en
permanence par le geste et par la parole
vous répondrez à guillaume daudin
ensuite le programme de marine le pen
conduirait la france ô malheur c'est ce
que nous disait ici même hier l'invité
qui étaient là
françois bayrou un conseiller politique
d' emmanuel macron et bien jean francis
pécresse vous demandera de démontrer le
contraire sur votre programme enfin
aucun sondage ne donne marine le pen
gagnante comment pouvez vous croire à
une victoire questions que vous posera
tout à l'heure mickaël szames s mais
d'abord une première question
d'actualité
[Musique]
n'oublions pas les questions
internationales dans cette campagne vous
êtes d'accord le ministre des affaires
étrangères jean marc ayrault a présenté
aujourd'hui un rapport des services de
renseignement français et qui met en
cause précisément bachar el-assad dans
la taxe chimiques qui avait fait 87
morts de nombreux enfonçons souvient le
4 avril dernier en zone rebelle est ce
que vous acceptez d'abord les
conclusions de ce rapport est ce que
vous acceptez ses preuves
je n'ai pas vu moi l'épreuve j'en sais
rien ce qu'il faut de soissons c'est une
enquête internationale sous supervision
de l'onu
parce qu'on a le passif vous avez
monsieur powell qui était arrivé aux six
épreuves ces petites fioles en 2003 pour
nous expliquer que l'irak de saddam
hussein avait des armes de destruction
massive est en fait ce rapport avait été
fait pour justifier une guerre voilà
tout cela était quand même doit inciter
à la prudence et vous mettez en cause la
probité d'une certaine manière des
services mais je pense que dans ce
domaine là il faut toujours une chance
qu'on a d'excellents services mais il
faut toujours une enquête internationale
pour qu'elle soit irréfutables et donc
sous sur la langue et l'ont traîné des
neiges unis arrivent après d'autres
enquêtes d'autres pays
oui ou des états unis va c'est toujours
un peu le même camp mais il je crois
qu'il faut sur cette affaire là aussi
réfléchir à une chose importante même si
c'est le régime de bachar ce qui est
tout à fait possible c'est quoi le plan
b qu'est ce qu'on fait je viens on peut
utiliser le rapport disant on va donc
aller dézinguer bombardent et tuent et
bachar el-assad et le retirer du pouvoir
très bien on l'a fait en irak en 2003
j'étais rabelais sera fourni en 2000 ont
considéré que la chair et la suède fait
toujours partie de la solution
bah c'est le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui c'est qui c'est quoi le
plan b c'est qu'il plombe et donc si ça
n'est pas lui c'est qui mais si vous
avez un plan b formidable quelqu'un un
grand démocrate qui va respecter les
minorités qui va combattre l'islamisme
radical
l'état islamique là bas et ce sera tant
mieux on sera les premiers à dire et si
les syriens
quand même sont d'accord parce que
n'oublions pas que normalement on est
censé respecter les principes
démocratiques
alors tant mieux mais sauf qu'on sait
bien que ça n'existe pas en tous les cas
ce serait donc il faut être extrêmement
prudent et ne pas mettre le feu à une
poudre il vous restait prudent
globalement sur la solution à apporter
également sur ce rapport qui vient
justifier quand même temps s'il en était
besoin les frappes américaines contre la
base de série n 2 était partie des
élevages très bien à quoi elles ont
servi avec moi pas je veux dire je vais
très bien qu'on les a servis si ce n'est
de rajouter du chaos au cas où peut-être
toujours là il faut toujours utiliser
l'expérience des 15 dernières années
l'irak en 2003 heureusement la france
disait la france de jacques chirac
disait non à l'époque libye 2011 nous on
disait non on l'a fait on a mis les
djihadistes une cas au pouvoir 2013 et
on en effet intervenir en 2013 la france
voulait intervenir en syrie
le nouveau président américain donald
trump qui à vos faveurs est intervenu
vous estimez pas que ce rapport france
est aujourd'hui légitime l'action de
l'armée américaine je je pense pas qu'il
faille aujourd'hui intervenir
militairement
tant qu'on n'a pas de plan b c'est aussi
simple que cela la diplomatie parfois
c'est l'art du moins pire
alors ça ne s'est pas notre ami comme
kadhafi n'était pas mais je veux dire au
bout d'un moment parfois on a encore
pire comment ça vous manque en ivoire
est longue et la preuve est apportée
encore une fois que c'est lui qui a
ordonné ces frappes au gaz sarin sur des
populations civiles comment est ce que
vous le qualifiez quand je qualifie
crois pas non bachar al assad a concédé
qualifie c'est un diktat
tu as tort oui c'est quelqu'un qui est
absurbe infréquentable c'est ça la
dictature infréquentable le roi d arabie
saoudite n'est pas non plus très
fréquentables l'émir du qatar au contenu
et à beaucoup un hélas beaucoup mais
ceci dit c'est ça le cil réalisme la
diplomatie c'est qu'il faut être capable
de faire des choix le choix du moins
pire parfois en tout cas l'objectif
principal ça doit être d'éradiquer
l'état islamique pour le moment ce ne
sont pas les troupes de bachar al assad
qui viennent tuer les français en france
ce sont les troupes djihadistes de
l'état islamique la suite de l'épreuve
de vérité donc avec l'actualité de ces
dernières heures sur le terrain social
avec guillaume daudin de la fp qui nous
rejoint maintenant l'épreuve de vérité
avec les françois guillemin soir bonsoir
monsieur philippe houillon soir il le
déplacement surprise donc ce matin de
marine le pen amiens quel était le but
de ce petit coup médiatique ce matin bon
c'est pas un coup médiatique parce que
nos équipes ils sont depuis des semaines
et des semaines et nos militants ils
sont nos élus locaux y sont ils sont là
sur le piquet de grève mais il était
auparavant déjà auprès des ouvriers des
employés qui se mobilisent et omar sy le
ben voilà on était en conseil
stratégique elle y aller j'y vais voilà
j'y vais parce que voyant que ses
ouvriers s'ils n'ont pas été
complètement abandonné que monsieur
macron se réfugie à 10 km dans une salle
pour discuter avec deux trois personnes
traitées faveur les abandonner discuter
sur le fond du dossier avec
l'intersyndicale
non il ya même eu un mensonge parce que
le disait ce matin qu'ils n'avaient pas
eu l'autorisation d'aller sur le site ce
qui est totalement faux
d'ailleurs il y est justement il y avait
là il était allé y allait y est allé et
donc il n'y a aucune interdiction marine
le pen n'a pas eu d' interdiction non
plus ce matin tout le monde peut y aller
et donc là il ya eu des mensonges quand
elle a entendu ce matin jacques attali
qui sont l'un de ses principaux
conseillers dire bah oui on le foot
c'est une anecdote c'est anecdotique 300
personnes mais sur le sur le carreau
c'est anecdotique les sous-traitants les
familles brisées la délocalisation en
pologne non il ya des choses à faire et
on peut maintenir ce site alors elle l a
été l a rencontré quelques salariés
manifestement il est resté quelques
minutes
elle n'a pas voulu rencontrer
l'intersyndicale comme l'a fait monsieur
macron il était à mieux non je vous en
mets où je sais pas où organiser un
rendez vous
sur les images j'ai pas de retour la
précis mais j'ai vu qu'ils avaient du
monde et qu'il y avait des syndiqués
puisque j'ai vu des chasubles de cgt
notamment qui prenaient des photos avec
à elle fin j'ai vu des caves et des
syndiqués des syndicalistes
et puis au delà de même de la chasuble
ils sont tous salariés sont à tous salle
louis-pol poule et ils voient tout cette
délocalisation en pologne comme une
injustice et ne pas annoncer comment
dire à la presse le déplacement c'est
une manière d'éviter peut-être les
manifestations d'hostilité d'autres
salariés de manière de faire que on
n'arrive pas avec 800 caméras et comme
c'est le cas dans l'entre-deux tours
d'une présidentielle ou quel que soit
votre de votre choix de déplacement vous
avez 800 caméras et journalistes qui
rend parfois les choses totalement 1
faisait l'impossible vous avez réussi
j'ai envie de dire un double coup
aujourd'hui parce qu'effectivement on a
vu marine le pen accueilli avec les
celles fi etc
on avait cessée lundi contre les
sifflets les sifflets mais les sifflets
qui l'ont été à qui sont-ils imputable
parce que il y avait les militants du
front national en fait ce sont des
sifflets des partisans de marine le pen
alors ça c'est la thèse macron c'est
qu'en fait les loyers sont des gens
complètement stupide pour un bond des
illettrés comme il disait
puisque ce matin il a dit marine le pen
a vu des militants sur un parking mais
qu'il leur dise ça en face l'appui je
crois qu'il y ait en ce moment sous les
sifflets et les mots difficiles qu'il
leur dise qu'il a osé dire ce matin tout
le mépris qu'il avait ses kilos alors
dire aussi que c'est une anecdote qui
leur arrive comme le dit sont un de ces
princes alors qu'ils sont bons si la
risée de dépôt d'un zinc rivaux le porte
parole allard mairie solidariser
désormais je veux dire maintenant est ce
que c'est vrai que en fête nationale par
les ouvriers et par les salariés parce
qu'il est détesté là bas parce qu'il
fait partie de cette oligarchie qui
créent des loisirs tué et qui n'a rien à
produire mais sur le fond rédac sap sont
impopulaires lorient philippot est ce
que vous pouvez confirmer ou de démentir
le fait que le front national en fait a
décidé de choisir amiens pour en faire
le symbole des délocalisations avec des
militants présents sur place depuis des
semaines des militants du front national
non c'est la direction girlschool qui a
décidé d'en faire un sujet lieu de
délocalisation ça c'est pas nous qui
avons malheureusement pris cette
décision triste je veux dire le front
social et oui les présents depuis des
semaines sur le terrain nos militants
ils sont nos élus notre secrétaire
départemental éric richard mosier depuis
des semaines et des semaines
et ce qui fait ce qui explique aussi
d'ailleurs que marine le pen a été aussi
bien accueilli parce qu'il n'ya pas de
ces partis fille ciel ils savent que les
militants et les élus du front ils sont
là avec eux sur le terrain depuis
longtemps et le temps et qui sont encore
là ils y seront demain ils seront après
maints même après le départ de mike donc
c'est une question et on a beaucoup de
militants en marche alors c'est une
manipulation
qu'est-ce qu'il mène bien sûr cette
présence cet activisme qu'est ce qu'une
manipulation d'aller voir des ouvriers
les de les soutenir non - est-ce là une
manipulation que d'aller proposer un
projet politique pour que l'usiné ne
ferme pas une taxe de 35 %
quand vous délocalisez que vous rien
mort question c'est ça c'est du fond
c'est un projet de réindustrialisation
question marine le pen était présente ce
matin à amiens combien de fois jusque là
elle s'était rendue auprès de salariés
en grève qui tenait des piquets de grève
elle a fait régulièrement des sorties
des usines à pessac et des sorties
d'usiné de la rue qui n'étaient pas en
grève
vous savez également vous savez les
ouvriers ici je crois qu'ils ont mis
marina carrère quasiment 40% au premier
tour d'après les enquêtes d'opinion
parce qu'ils savent ce qui dans ce qu'il
en est voilà et bakr on doit être à 10
ou 15%
parce qu'ils savent ce qu'il en est il y
en a un qui défend la mondialisation
sauvage les délocalisations voilà il
voit la france comme une grande salle de
marché alors évidemment forcément les
ouvriers n'ont plus leur place là dedans
et puis à marine le pen qui pensent que
est content il ya du travail le matin
des ouvriers et des syndiqués de l'usiné
hier comme je l'avais il a rencontré
quelques personnes mais dans un dans une
salle loin en faisant croire qu'il n'a
pas le droit d'aller sur l' usine ce
qu'il faut comme ça est un fiasco pour
emmanuel macron mais pas un fiasco
jaillir artificiel c'est un fiasco
basque un problème sur le fond il a un
problème de relation avec le monde du
travail dans rappelle qu'il y est allé
quand même cet après midi même s'il ya
eu des sifflets 1 bat vue de ce fait du
fait que marine il est allé il est lé
oui donc l'interdiction d'un coup a
sauté alors david rachline votre pseudo
interdiction david racines votre le
directeur de campagne de marine le pen a
présenté ce matin la fiche de second
tour donc d'un côté on à choisir la
france bon pour marine le pen répond
monsieur macron ces ensembles la france
on a vu dimanche qu' il s' est
revendiquée du camp des patriotes face
aux nationalistes que vous représentez
riez est ce que c'est un second tour
justement voilà front contre front
on se dispute la question du patriotisme
du drapeau tricolore
vous voyez ça comme ça sert qui s'est
positionné par rapport à nous parce que
le fait que nous disions que
politiquement nous sommes patriotes ça
fait des années et des années
c'est ce qui nous caractérise et d'un
coup lui en eux depuis une semaine se
découvre patriotes dire tant mieux tant
mieux s'ils se découvre patriotes sauf
que l'amour il faut des preuves pour le
pour le pour le démontrer si vous voulez
le patriotisme de c'est la même chose
alors moi je suis désolé quand on a
largué les fleurons nationaux quand il
était ministre de l'économie monsieur
hollande donc alstom lafarge technip
quand on a privatisé des aéroports
toulouse nice lyon lui dit avoir permis
de souris par exemple psa avec
l'intervention de l'état on peut donner
d'autres exemples
oui enfin éclater je crois que psa
heureusement qu'il a essayé de savourer
mais d'accord mais est-ce qu'il a
sécurisé véritablement l'entreprise est
ce qu'il a vraiment une stratégie un
discours l'instant elle est florissante
comme job
est-ce qu'il va pas laisser le chinois
grignoter peu à peu capri déjà 14% je
crois un peu plus peut-être maintenant
cette entreprise il ya quand même des
questions qui se posent mais pendant ce
temps là combien de fleurons nationaux
partait à l'étranger
monsieur macron il mais il veut mettre
la france sous tutelle européenne encore
plus avec un gouvernement de la zone
euro c'est-à-dire qu'on déciderait
encore moins en france
il dit qu a pas de culture française que
ça n'existe pas ça pour moi on peut
faire mieux en matière de patriotisme on
veut faire mieux faire mieux que de dire
des choses aussi désagréable et de faire
des choses aussi désagréable contre son
pays dans toutes les déclarations du
front national avant même ce premier le
premier tour et depuis on a un peu
l'impression qu'en toile de fond le
slogan le résume bien ce sentiment
choisir la france
macron pour vous ça serait quelque chose
comme l'anti france c'est quelque chose
qui n'est pas non je reprends la vaste
expression c'est simplement ils
considèrent que la france c'est une
salle de marché les hommes des
paramètres
il a une vision très marchande du monde
en fait simplement il a une vision
marchande où tout a un prix tout a un
coût
alors évidemment un chômeur ça vaut pas
grand chose donc on lui sucre c'est dans
une unité très rapidement c'est dans son
projet un retraité ça vaut pas grand
chose c'est improductif donc
donc on va le taq s'est cassé lg voilà
avec ça c'est le monde de monsieur macro
on doit travailler dimanche ça on est
tout le temps producteurs consommateurs
et ça c'est gênant du point de vue
vision du monde la vision les danseurs
de l'homme dans son programme concernant
l'union européenne un sujet qui vaut qui
vous oppose pas mal il veut renforcer
les droits sociaux il me semble il veut
des standards communs en matière
d'assurance chômage de des choses comme
ça une couverture santé enfin des
standards en matière de couverture santé
c'est pas quelque chose qui est sur
lequel oui mais ça c'est du maquereau ça
veut dire quoi
je veux des standards européens en
matière de santé c'est ce que c'est une
forme d'harmonisation sociale ça me fait
penser aux 48 heures de travail maximum
par semaine c'est le standard européen
bas ça nous convient pas c'est beaucoup
48 heures ça convenait à d'autres
candidats mais pas nous et puis la
france pour lui pour revenir à la fiche
choisir la france parce que la france
pour lui c'est un terrain vague quoi
tout le monde se vaut donc on fait venir
des migrants nouveau les frontières
financières commerciales migratoires
voilà je ne sens pas si vous voulez
cette dimension patriotique pour le coup
il peut se revendiquer patriotes mais on
la sent pas du tout ni dans sa manière
d'être sa manière de de se faire et
danses ont prouvé alors je le disais
tout à l'heure vous avez décidé de
défier c'est votre stratégie par par
part par le geste par la part la parole
aussi parce que leur là je peux dire que
grossiste et le trèbes et vous les
faites un procès d'intention absolument
sûr tous azimuts qua non je crois que
les dévoiler peut-être qu'avant le
premier tour il a bénéficié en espèces
de brouillard c'étaient les discours
creux il enchaîné des phrases marketing
assez creuse dans les dix dans ses
meetings tous des reportages d'ailleurs
les gens sortaient de la salle sont pas
très bien ce qu'il avait dit ce qu'ils
avaient pas dit grand chose
il a il est obligé de se dévoiler et on
voit le personnage y compris même dans
ses réactions les plus et plus les plus
immédiates les moins contrôlés peut-être
quand il parle djoudi l'amiante il a
réagi sur la visite de marine le pen à
whirlpool est significative
il avait l'air assez agacé énervé et
méprisant on a retrouvé le mcs ronde et
il est très de gad
bon alors il a déclaré par ailleurs
aujourd'hui à amiens
la france n'a jamais été ce que marine
le pen propose sauf dans ces heures
sombres et je vous propose d'écouter ce
que dit jean daniel lévy harris
interactive qui évoquait un front du
refus justement d'une majorité
d'électeurs vis-à-vis de marine le pen
sur ce dernier thème on l'écouté puis
vous réagissez aujourd'hui la dynamique
électorale ne serait pas entièrement
ressentir il ya plus de personnes qui
souhaitent que marine le pen ne soit pas
président l'appliquent que des personnes
qui ne souhaitent pas l'élection et
emmanuel macron donc il y à un front du
refus qui existe aujourd'hui de manière
relativement n'êtes pas forcément
uniquement sur les thématiques en
matière d'immigration et de sécurité
mais autour de l'idée que l'image de la
france l'image qu'ils se font au menu de
la france serait altérée par la présence
de marine le pen à la présidence de la
république
comment est-ce que vous réagissez cette
analyse non ça se pense que c'est un peu
du blablatage de son dard image de la
france et il est l'image de marine le
pen guen ont je pense que vous savez on
est déjà à 40% là on va on est
challenger moi je me fais pas
d'illusions on n'est pas favoris dans
cette élection
macron les il pense déjà qu'il a gagné
d'ailleurs il a déjà fêté sa victoire au
fouquet's à la rotonde et moi je pense
que ceci dit on peut convaincre et qu'on
peut gagner voilà il n'y a pas de
frontières chat ça me fait penser aux
analyses de sondeurs quelques mois avant
la constitution open en disant
structurellement les français ne
pourront que dire oui parce que
structurellement il adore l'union
européenne et ça puis en guinée sur
cette idée justement d'un front du refus
que marine le pen ferait peur un certain
nombre d'électeurs on voit cette astuce
de second tour à nouveau avec marine le
pen qui pose devant une bibliothèque
c'est une image un peu traditionnelle de
président de la république c'est ça vise
à mettre les électeurs en situation à
leur dire c'est faisable c'est crédible
de voir marine le pen à l'elysée il y a
il ya une marine le pen qui démontre
aussi qu'il ya une culture en france la
vinothèque est un symbole de la culture
française la littérature et en même
temps cette affiche elle est très belle
elle est allée à l'esc et marino
naturelle naturelle cette affiche c'est
pour ça qu'elle plaît d'ailleurs j'ai là
elle n'a pas changé un petit peu sa
stratégie médiatique parce qu'on l'a vu
par exemple hier soir sur tf1 tout
sourire vous avez remarqué
elle a même parlé des enfants qui ont
grandi un don qu'elle a décidé quoi
l'arrondir les angles de corriger
l'image qu'elle est loin de brutalité
dans le nord ce que je pense qu'elle est
aussi très très heureuse voilà parce que
la tosca l'attendait ce débat depuis
longtemps
oui d'être second tour d'avoir ce débat
qui est quand même extrêmement
intéressant ça fait longtemps que la
france a pas eu un peut-être depuis le
référendum de 2005
ça me fait penser à 2005 moi c'était ce
second tour c'est pour ça que c'est un
peu un référendum et on sait comment ça
s'est terminé
ça s'est terminé par près de 55 grainger
mai 2005 justement c'est un très bon
exemple ça a été permis par une certaine
coalition une coalition contre la
constitution européenne
or la coalition n'a pas l'air de se
mettre en place autour de marine le pen
il n'y a pas vraiment de de soutien
déclaré peut-être christine boutin
peut-être la manif pour tout ce qu'ils
appellent à voter mais nitreux macron
est-ce que je finis ma question est ce
que par exemple avec nicolas dupont
aignan il ya des négociations en cours
des discussions
ok vous rejoindre il faut toujours
discuter ce sont là les plaignants il a
fait un bon score enfin beaucoup plus
que tendue cédé près de 5% et et nous
avons un projet que far vous le savez à
95% à peu près identique souverainiste
régulation l'immigration et refus de la
casse sociale adoma question c'est
est-ce que vous discutez avec lui en ce
moment par vous ou des gens ou des
émissaires frontiste il y a toujours des
discussions avec il faut toujours
discuter avec ses amis en politique et
dupont aignan fait partie de nos amis il
est évoqué après les titres des
circonscriptions il a dit lui-même qui
s'exprimerait après avoir consulté ses
instances internes
si vous avez besoin par une espoir de
ralliement vous avez un bon espoir
ouais je blesse pas ce n'est pas leur
espace à un ralliement j'appellerais ça
à un soutien ce serait contre soi serait
contre des circonscriptions contre le
remboursement de ces femmes croient que
nicolas dupont aignan est suffisamment
un homme de conviction pour prendre des
décisions d'abord de conviction après si
on peut aller encore plus loin
législatif faire des accords électoraux
parce que tu fasses on partage tout on
fera on fera un grand grande alliance
patriote est là j'en serai encore plus
heureux
voilà ça fait on était l'appel moi cette
maudite y compris jusqu'aux législatives
voilà bon vous dit peut-être dans les
tuyaux puisque vous êtes confiant
s'exprimera bien tous d'accord merci
beaucoup
guillaume la suite de l'épreuve de
vérité maintenant avec jean francis
pécresse le directeur de la rédaction de
radio classique
bonsoir
enfin michel bonsoir florian philippon
soir première question qu'on va évoquer
tout de suite avec je crois françois
bayrou exactement sur notre plateau hier
sur la crédibilité du projet économique
du front national on peut écouter tout
de suite le président du modem conseillé
d' emmanuel macron puisqu'il a eu des
mots très durs pour ce programme dont
vous êtes grandement à l'origine dans
les côtes
si on suivait les directions que madame
le pen propose on aurait le malheur pour
la france est en france pour les plus
faibles de la france
on aurait le malheur parce que si on
sortait de l'euro pour revenir au franc
la monnaie se casserait la figure et que
donc les retraites par exemple ne
vaudrait plus le montant du chèque le
pouvoir d'achat s'effondrerait on aurait
d'incroyables difficultés budgétaires
par exemple tous ceux qui veulent
emprunter pour construire une maison
pour acheter une voiture pour de
l'électroménager y verrez les taux
d'intérêts explosé et ceci est si
vérifier au travers du monde chaque fois
qu'on a essayé ça que d'une certaine
manière il nous revient à tous comme
citoyen comme spécialiste pour vous
comme citoyen pour moi de dire la vérité
au pays alors florian philippot est ce
que vous ferez le malheur des français
mais monsieur bayrou est un homme qui
n'a pas de colonne vertébrale
idéologique parce que je rappelle que
quelques mois avant de rejoindre
emmanuel macron et on a toutes les
traces encore il disait à peu près la
même chose dans des termes aussi le
grandiloquent est aussi inquiétant
concernant le projet d' emmanuel macron
expliqué non ils nous expliquent ces
déclarations nous expliquait un homme
sous influence des puissances d'argent
ça n'était pas l'homme de l'association
et qui n'avait française il n'avait pas
la capacité les qualités pour être
président de la république etc etc
il impliquait pas du tout que emmanuel
que emmanuel macron aller faire la ruine
des les épargnants fortunés mettre le
tout les déclarations pas il avait il
avait une divergence sur le personnage
sur son origine est sur rails sur les
influences et sur les influences ici et
sur les ambulances police d'argent les
puissances d'argent qui influent sur le
projet politique du personnage non mais
attendez quand on dit cela elle a
quelqu'un et je le soutiens juste après
sur le fait on a une vraiment sur le
fond et même à parler s'il vous plaît
vrai pour des toujours sur le plateforme
sur les gens sur les personnes gênant
sur le zinc m'accrochant à le réaliser
dans les médias on veut pas qu'on n'a
pas choisi une question mme fu fu somme
qui est tombée très pesée des devoirs
l'attaqué sur son programme à cause que
là la question pour tout le programme
alors à vos réponses comme je veux me
suis moi voilà ça n'est pas vous
monsieur pécresse qui allait me
disposons dégradation s'y posent les oui
mais je fais dans l'apparence voyez mes
réponses je les construis comme je ne
souris mais moi j'avais le droit de vous
poser mes questions
laissez moi parler bon alors allez-y
alors donc je vous le redis je
continuerai mon idée même si ça ne vous
plaît pas ou si elle vous dérange à
l'oreille monsieur bayrou est quelqu'un
qui manque de constance et qui manque de
sincérité
parce que quand on dit de telles choses
sur quelqu'un qu'on soutient quelques
semaines après avec tant de ferveur
c'est qu'on a un vrai problème de
cohérence ou de sincérité a saisi pour
remet aux premières heures deux avants
sur le fond bombe à cela la vulgate
traditionnel des gens qui essaient de
faire peur les mêmes d'expliquer que le
vote du break zita les conduira à ce que
le royaume uni se détache du continent
européen
est-ce que ce soit la nuit noire au
royaume uni ce soit là la catastrophe et
sait pas du tout ce qui se produit sont
pas encore sorties était dévalué de 15
pour ce qui est une excellente nouvelle
pour le royaume uni ce qui a boosté son
tourisme ses exportations c'est ce qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui le royaume uni a une
patience beaucoup plus forte que nous
non c'est pas vrai et qu'elle importe
beaucoup beaucoup plus cher ce cas ce
n'est pas vrai que le royaume uni n'a
pas une sorcière tendue cet avion ce
qu'elle importait avant elle scanne
importe beaucoup plus cher ce qu'elle
importait avant lui mais plutôt anglais
n'est pas vrai en train de se rendre
compte de leur erreur
mais allez-y monsieur monsieur pécresse
maintenu il pas vrai que le royaume uni
à une croissance plus forte que nous non
mais en ce moment oui c'est le s'il
l'était dans les jeux
intéressante qui nous a innové château
anglais était sur une pente de leur vie
dans la terreur de leur erreur une telle
erreur ne vous échappe pas que la paire
de rennes n'a pas encore quitté l'union
européenne de monsieur philippe monsieur
cochrane viennent de keller d'actionner
l'article 50 d'avoir risque d'avoir voté
contre pour la sortie du nord je vous
amène je veux vraiment je vous appelle à
relire les analyses de l'époque qui nous
expliquer que rien que le vote le vote
allait mettre en condition psychologique
les marchés les producteurs les
investisseurs etc
de tels signaux salle est la ruine at
elle eu lieu la récré il ya un peu poli
je veux bien par m'énerver soyez polis
j'essaie de série seront donc les
téléspectateurs comprennent mais je veux
la grande-bretagne mal à quitter la zone
au bout alors allez-y répondait monsieur
à l'ailé répondait répondait oui on va
parler surtout de la fira laissez moi
finir mon idée vous avez tort
les la banque d'angleterre disait à
l'époque rien que le vote du brésil
allait conduire à une preuve un problème
économique et à les mettre en récession
le royaume uni en 2016 en 2016 avant la
sortie
à tel point et vous devriez vous
renseigner que l'heureux que la banque
d'angleterre en septembre est venu
s'excuser par communiqué de presse en
disant qu'il s'était trompé
alors l'organisme bien sûr la france à
la bombe ont fait au niveau d'un jean et
de la france on va parler de votre moi
j'ai pour la france qui écrit priez des
leçons plus d'un 2 est ce que notre
argent ville et les domaines oui tout
arrive nous voulons suivre l europe est
ce que quand on quand on entend bien
marine le pen hier sur pendant toute ma
question je suis la question savait
alors la question quand on entend bien
marine le pen hier soir sur tf1
elle dit maintenant c'est un instrument
de négociation avec avec l'europe et
donc ma question est est ce que vous
avez vraiment toujours comme intention
de quitter l'euro votre rêve nous vivons
notre projet l'éclair nous arrivons pour
négocier le retour de nos souveraineté
monétaire nous avez votre réponse
territoriale nos frontières rapport à
l'immigration législatives que nos lois
soit supérieur au droit européen et
économique qu'on a le droit de faire du
patriotisme économique confère par
exemple ou dans le pool et à la fin il y
aura de toutes façons à référendum
et c'est ça qui est une arme de
négociation parce que ce que dit marine
le pen
si vous arrivez à une négociation sans
référendum vous êtes faible parce que de
toute façon la commission en face ou
l'allemagne vous dira de toute façon si
vous n'êtes pas d'accord ce sera quand
même vous prendrez quand même d'accord
et puis tant pis non nous on se tournera
vers les français et c'est eux qui
décideront de toute façon au final
monsieur bayrou qui nous donne pas de
leçons d'économie et budget il a
participé à je ne sais combien de
gouvernement depuis 20 ans ou 25 ans qui
ont tous mis la france à la ruine qui
ont tous aggraver la dette de la france
y compris les derniers qui ont augmenté
de plusieurs centaines de milliards
d'euros notre dette y compris les
derniers qu augmenter de plusieurs
millions le nombre de chômeurs je n'ai
pas de leçon à recevoir de monsieur
bayou certainement là et ça c'est un
gars de la vieille politique qui tourne
qui grenouillent autour de monsieur
macron le bayrou robert hue comme sur
grâce monsieur hollande d'absents mais
ça c'est le renouvellement de maquereaux
envoyé ça c'est là on est sur la
question maintenant on est posé la
question on est sur votre projet à fou
et je voudrais comprendre comment ça va
se passer
le franc va être tout convertibles
manière libre je suppose c'est ça il y
aura une parité inférant un moment en
france pas l'ancien nouveau grand régal
un euro vers avons donc une parité fixe
que vous allez fixez-vous même
d'autorité donc ya pas deux comme de la
part du passage à l'euro en avant via
rafah sénégal 6 à 25 5 d'avancé après ce
passage là la convertibilité et le taux
de change ce rallye sera fixée de
manière libre par les marchés je suppose
que vous n'allez pas exactement quand il
le franc va probablement selon le fmi se
déprécier de 7 à 10% alors ce qui sera
une bonne chose c'est à dire parce
qu'aujourd'hui il est trop fort et il
nous plonge dans nos exportations il
nous plonge dans notre compétitivité
à tel point attendait monsieur pécresse
à tel point que nous avons un déficit
c'est le fmi qui le dit en août dernier
un déficit de 21 points de compétitivité
par rapport à l'allemagne a rien qu'à
cause de la monnaie alors moi je veux
bien qu'on fasse autrement mais ça
s'appelle le projet macro on augmente la
csg ça s'appelle le la baisse des
salaires la baisse des retraites ou la
destruction du modèle social et des
services publics
sinon on peut accepter d'utiliser un
instrument classique utilise 95% des
pays du monde qui s'appelle la monnaie
comme on doit utiliser les frontières
face à la concurrence internationale
déloyale comme on doit utiliser l'état
stratège pour réindustrialiser notre
pays bref ce qu'on veut c'est un peu
simplement redonner des armes à la
france dans la mondialisation parce
qu'aujourd'hui elle est complètement
battu
par la mondialisation traversée de
l'ipar et elle ne se défend pas question
une petite question compte tenu de
l'ampleur de nos déficits extérieurs de
notre déficit commercial qui est de
soude qui est de 50 milliards de la
faute aux déficits budgétaires liées
2,70 milliards de roubles je vais juste
une il est fort probable que la
dévaluation que la dépréciation pour
être exact du nouveau franc sera plus
forte que 10 à 15% et probablement même
de 20%
c'est ce qui s'était passé lorsque la
lire italienne avait quitté le système
monétaire européen en 1992
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire de
manière très automatique que notre
volume notre masse de dette publique
française
elle augmentera de 20 % non et que
pourquoi non mais si c'est mathématique
ne connaissons malheureusement sauf à ce
que vous renonciez sauf à ce que vous
renonciez à rembourser une partie de
cette dette et que alors alors la
caravane non banon la dette publique
s'est pas ne s'est pas la monnaie qui
détermine c'est le contre al c'est la
nationalité du contrat nous avons une
dette publique à 98 5% en contrats de
droit français dont elle sera redéfinie
en monnaie française les défauts et les
doigts pour cent de la dette pas du tout
mais on va vivre demain elle sera
remboursable en france mais monsieur
aulas le dévaluer de 20% par rapport par
rapport à l'ancienne monnaie non mais
vous allez répondre je ne peux pas vous
laisser dire n'importe quoi je peux pas
vous laisser vous êtes à l'amusant
d'importance et un débatteur monnaie
même valeur de 20 % si vous la
rembourser dans une dans une monnaie qui
est déprécié de 20%
elle vous 20% plus alors l'arrêt pour
vous la règle même si vous la rembourser
en moins
s'il faut bosser quoi autres refusés
c'était quoi sur économique alary de
meetic sport c'est parce que vous vous
connaissez pas ce choix et parce que
vous connaissez pas le même
c'est pas une question de droit c'est
une question d'arithmétique économie
alors je peux vraiment leurs repères et
on s'arrêtera là
monsieur pécresse ne travaille pas il
connaît pas le droit international je
vais vous envoyer travailler connaître
mieux
les connaître alors maintenant je vais
voir parler vous allez arrêter je vais
vous envoyer l'étude de l'oefe c'est eux
qui dénoncent que reste la question vous
gêne c'est ça non non je vous réponds
que vous allez on laisse répondre en
être invité jean vous ne devez pas le
sujet vous n'avez pas trahi leur votre
réponse réponse notre dette étant à 98
5% en droit français
donc selon la lex monétaire qui est la
norme internationale de la monnaie nous
rembourserons dans la monnaie française
donc votre arwing éthique et fraudes et
a déjà deuxièmement vous dites sa vache
d'évaluer de 20 à 30% au hasard
n'importe quoi
le fmi l'a dit de manière très claire ça
se dévaluera de 7 à 11%
le marque serait évaluera de 10 à 15%
parce que c'est la valeur d'équilibré ne
la monnaie c'est un petit corps je suis
désolé d'être aussi relevé que la wii
mais vous vous faites partie du projet
peur vous êtes payé pour ça et c'est de
faire peur aux gens mais poste-là il ya
aurait les nobel d'économie qui le
disent aussi est la dette publique de la
france est détenue à 60% par des
investisseurs étrangers
si votre l'ex monétaires n'ont pas grand
chose à faire mais pas du tout c'est du
droit international donné aux pressions
et aux français c'est du droit à un
niveau de recettes ce sera la dernière
quand les entreprises françaises sont
sont endettés elle même l es deux
devront aussi faire des remboursements
elles devront vous rembourser en francs
leurs propres dettes vis-à-vis de dettes
qui libellées en euros donc vous allez
esprits ce que les patrons disent
d'ailleurs les conduire à la ruine
qu'est ce que vous répondez pas ce que
disent les patrons ou bien sûr de 6 à ce
qu'ils disent
vous connaissez pas savez vous que les
patrons de pme ne parlera plus j'ai déjà
joué des matches avec lui il y en a un
qui envoyaient leurs âmes à les vendre
on écoute la réponse car ce sera la
dernière et lens deux plans sociaux
comme un bon paternaliste il envoie une
lettre à ses employés ça ne vous plait
relais paternaliste un bon paternaliste
il envoyé une lettre à ses salariés
il a l'air de le glorifier ce patron il
a envoyé une lettre à ses employés en
disant vous devez voter comme dans mes
bottines ouvertes et moi sont
extrêmement jeu je les admire et à moi
une des facettes avait la télé vous
savez que votre état d'esprit je lui dis
à lui joué je lui ai
j attendais monsieur lui non plus on
s'entend que je suis désolé je vous ai
je l'avais en débat je le voudrais je le
prends comme je l'avais en débat je lui
ai dit que ses méthodes étaient
paternaliste un pas trop moi je serai
dans une boîte on n'a pas trop en vers
et à ses salariés une lettre pour leur
dire avant le premier tour comment voter
mais je me sauverait en courant parce
que je suis un salarié
j'ai autant de cerveaux que monsieur le
plus grand patron mais étrangers d'avoir
comme henry ce que je peux atteindre le
fond sur le prenant dans les entreprises
françaises
elle crève de l'austérité créé par
l'austérité européenne et notamment par
l'euro elle crève de ces politiques là
vous parliez tout à l'heure à raison du
déficit commercial
on a atteint un record historique en
janvier dernier de déficit commercial
nous sommes en déficit commercial depuis
l'euro avant on était en excédent
commercial donc moi je veux bien qu'on
m'explique juste que l'euro est
formidable etc
sauf que depuis qu'on à l'euro on est
passé à 6 mio ebit chômeurs les prix ont
explosé lors du passage à l'euro et ça
le déficit commercial des vénitiens pas
envie de manquer les allemands
bénéficient d'une monnaie qui est à
davos avec le nomic en 250 milliards de
zim le haut et les conseils de nombreux
commercial il est justement sont aussi
l'euro merci au sein de la zone euro
mais justement il n'y a pas tout change
on ne va pas non parce qu'avant nous
pouvions adapter nos monnaies les unes
par rapport aux autres on ne peut sous
le merci on a compris on a compris le
débat et la dengue fessée il pourrait se
prolonger ou des déficits français et
italiens se dévoile à gimont s'arrêter
là mais je prends la parole si on la
ferme à mon départ n'a pas terminé mais
moi j'ai terminé je pouvais je dirige
s'est terminée juste une chose avait dit
tout à l'heure à donner juste une chose
si on ne change pas les règles
européennes par la négociation et ce
référendum ce soit l'euro mais pas que
ça la directive détachement des
travailleurs schengen l'ouverture totale
des frontières la concurrence déloyale
alors nous continuerons dans la ruine
parce que ceux qui disent faut rien
changer c'est quoi leur recette
alors on a continué ce qu'on a fait
depuis 15 ans on attend que vous avez un
produit du chômage vous avez dit tout à
l'heure que vous étiez les challengers
dans cette poule devant toi là vous avez
été challenger par jean-francis pécresse
merci jean francis cette troisième
partie et dernière partie de l'épreuve
de la riche mais les graisses avec
monsieur pécresse - avec maintenant
c'est mickaël szames est ce qui arrive
bonsoir michael
[Musique]
filippo comment pouvez-vous gagner alors
qu emmanuel macron reçoit encore
aujourd'hui des soutiens et notamment
celui de nicolas sarkozy
est ce que ça vous surprend d'abord
baïla et soutient le lay archimède après
les images qu'on a vue des alpes où il
n'a pas le soutien de la population et
les sages crois que ça devrait inquiéter
moi ça me surprend pas que j'ai vu le
président de la commission européenne
j'ai vu liu wei f les islamistes de
l'uefa prêts à voter pour lui j'ai vu
hani ramadan qui a été viré de france et
quelques jours passés tour
radicalisation islamiste voulait dire
qu'aussi j'ai vu monsieur j'ai vu le ps
veut hollande j'ai vu valls qui a dit
qu'il voulait faire partie de son
gouvernement
tout cela j'ai vu madame parisot qui
quémandent déjà un terroriste oblique à
l'ancienne du medef des républiques j'ai
vu des républicains pas tous mais j'en
ai vu effectivement nommé quand j'étais
république tout ça le même sens large
non mais républicain l'est républicain
je leur fais ça m'étonne pas c'est tout
le ligue archi qui se coalisent autour
de sa candidature et de son candidat
c'est tout et ça c'est la preuve qu'il
est un candidat coupé de la réalité
c'est le candidat lollia jours résumé en
tant qu il défend la politique résumé
l'opinion publique et les vendeurs on
fera la remonte taddart et philippe nous
avons dit poindre montana a fait rêver
on va la faire joyeusement dans une
dizaine de vous vous coupez la france en
deux il ya les partisans de marine le
pen et tous les autres c'est
l'oligarchie non
l'homme est le nom que je vous ai
inventées sont des noms que raymond sont
des noms les banques je vous ai cités ce
sont les noix des organisations qui font
la politique de la france depuis vingt
ou trente ans lorsque vous réellement ce
sont les gens qui sont au pouvoir aux
manettes économiquement politiquement ou
même pour l'uejf du point de vue des
associations islamistes depuis vingt ou
trente ans et qui nous ont pas conduit
au faut quand même le reconnaîtra à
mieux à un mieux il nous faut plutôt
conduit à un moins bien la politique
enfin la situation des français pouvoir
d'achat la santé les retraites philippe
leur sécurité est quand même dégradée et
quand la manif pour tous et christine
boutin vous rejoignent c'est quoi ben
moi j'ai vu la même pour tous dire il
faut pas voter pour macron parce qu'il
est le candidat anti famille bah ils ont
raison voilà ils ont raison quand on
veut augmenter la csg sur les ça va
peser sur les familles en premier quand
on a été ministre et qu'on a gelé les
allocations familiales
ça pèse sur les familles quand on a
un projet de loi et les conneries plus
par ordonnance c'est à dire qu'on va
précariser encore plus les pères et les
mères de famille donc on va précariser
la situation des familles françaises
j'ai en moi je regarde tout ça c'est ça
la situation concrète des familles et je
crois que oui c'est effectivement
monsieur macron à un projet qui est dur
pour les familles françaises
marine le pen elle veut les aider à
lever augmenté de 25% les apl pour les
jeunes de moins de 27 ans elle veut
aider les allocations familiales et les
soutenir davantage voilà elle veut aider
les petites retraites et les revaloriser
alain vrai projet supprimés si vous
voulez là enfin remettre en place la
demi part pour les veufs et les veuves
qui avait été supprimée par le passé
tout cela ça fait partie d'une grande
politique familiale est programmé et
fait partie du programme des cent
premiers jours de marine le pen est ce
qu'on a entendu hier à rungis où elle
disait elle parlé de trahison autour de
françois fillon
est ce que vous appelez aujourd'hui sur
ce plateau par exemple a demandé aux
électeurs de françois villon nous vous
rejoindre nouveauté pauvres même nous
appelons tous les électeurs à notamment
saulxures mais bien sûr nos trahisons
mais bien pour quoi elle parle de
trahison à la raison parce que monsieur
fillon fait sa campagne en parlant des
manuels hollande c'est le sobriquet
qu'il avait choisi pour pour monsieur
macron plutôt bien trouvée il faut le
dire puisque effectivement le sait
maintenant c'était un secret de
polichinelle mais c'est maintenant
avouer que depuis le début macron et
candidat de hollande bon et même me
royal jeudi sur la question même la main
royale hier a dit notre candidat l'a
emporté au premier tour donc à la saga
les électeurs de droite
non mais voilà et donc ces électeurs là
il voit monsieur fillon d'un coup en
deux minutes dire bah finalement faut
voter pour emmanuel hollande
je pense qu'ils se sentent trahis oui
effectivement et qu'ils n'ont pas envie
d'un candidat notamment qui va ouvrir
grand les frontières de la table l
émigration catholique par exemple c'est
quelque chose que vous ciblez
particulièrement moi j'ai jamais
raisonné alors pour le coup vraiment pas
en communauté que ce soit religieuse ou
d'origine ou c'est pas ça n'est pas
notre manière de et la manière de
concevoir la société française
il ya des catholiques les gens qui sont
juifs musulmans protestants de tout
bouddhistes athées y en a beaucoup aussi
et je ne refuse toujours à couper les à
découper la population française en
tranche emmanuel macron a dit
aujourd'hui le front républicain
n'existe plus il a raison bah oui il
n'existe plus il ne peut plus exister
parce que les gens ont compris que sur
le fond ça n'avait pas de sens il faut
s'attarder un peu sur le fond
républicain qui républicain ceux qui
trahissent les français sur le traité de
lisbonne alors que les français avaient
dit non ça c'est pas du tout républicain
s'est même pas démocrates ceux qui
battent en brèche nos valeurs de liberté
d'égalité de fraternité et même la
laïcité
depuis des années ça n'est pas
républicain ceux qui ont transféré la
souveraineté populaire à des gens non
élus
ça n'est pas républicain donc je veux
dire et donc il ya plus de prises dans
la population et les français ont
compris larnack ont compris que c'était
juste pour sauver leur poste leur place
et le plafond de verre il existe ou pas
non je crois qu'il n'existe pas soit
qu'il existe plus et où alors il est au
dessus de 50 pour cent et ça me va
et pour justement dépasser ce plafond de
verre grimper grimper
vous en avez également aux électeurs de
jean luc mélenchon with a soumis les un
programme que jean luc mélenchon le
programme de marine le pen c'est le même
nom je mettrai pas les programmes dans
une balance pour les soupeser mais on
connaît nos divergences y compris que
monsieur fillon on les a pas caché elles
n'ont pas disparu mais là c'est un choix
entre deux personnes et les insoumis
voudront pas d'une france soumise à
toutes les tutelles de la banque de
l'union européenne de la finance les
insoumis vont pas vouloir du banquier de
monsieur hollande
ils vont pas vouloir de celui qui veut
une loi elle comme brille plus par
ordonnance encore pire que le 49-3 voyez
ouais moi je les invite à réfléchir
vraiment c'est une réflexion que chaque
citoyenne et chaque citoyen français
doit avoir il reste dix jours et c'est
très important ça regarde les armes a
relevé le porte parole de jean luc
mélenchon a déclaré aujourd'hui pas une
voix un pour le front national
il l'a dit oui et monsieur mélenchon a
dit moi je donnerai pas mon vote jusqu'à
la fin et alors moi je trouve que c'est
plus courageux que ce café fillon salué
le geste de jean luc mélenchon c'est
plus pour ça me semble honnêtement
beaucoup plus cohérent et et et sincère
peut-être ce qu'a fait monsieur fillon
je me place vu la campagne de premier
tour de jean luc mélenchon des questions
premières hypothèses marine
gagnon présidentielle sa mesure la plus
urgente et son déplacement principal le
premier jour ça c'est quoi
moi je pense que sa mesure la plus
urgente si leur établissement nos
frontières nationales
ça c'est le gentil si il ya des drames
on l'a encore vu malheureusement il ya
peu et il faut retrouver les frontières
nationales ça c'est très rapide première
visite elle l'a dit c'est à bruxelles on
pourra les germes et turquie étaient
engagés dans cette n'ont pas fait une
promesse dont la fermeture des
frontières c'est une promesse
mensongères a déclaré tout à l'heure
emmanuel macron à amiens ou mais
personne n'a demandé la fermeture
nous nous le voulons tout simplement
déjà en avoir ce qui serait déjà pas mal
et ensuite les maîtriser vous avez la
frontière c'est pas un mur c'est un
filtre et les travailleurs frontaliers
par exemple ils auront des passes 6
passes faciles membres et par contre les
trafics passeront moins bien les
clandestins il ou elle perd l'élection à
vous et à la langue alors un grand
honneur il veut ce biais mais cette
dernière hypothèse si elle perd
l'élection présidentielle n'ont pas été
ce qui se passe est ce que c'est la
crise au front national est ce qu elle
peut encore rester présidente nous avons
vice-président ya aucune situation de
crise au front national de cette façon
mais quand on perd on ya des désaccords
je me place dans une stratégie de
victoire
vous avez composé de contradictoire
puisque vous avez dit non alors vous
êtes challenger on va pas gagner ce oui
vous avez raison c'est prier claire
l'art roman de talence alors oui alors
douter et on veut tenait ces propos
contradictoires sur votre pronostic
soyez clair
donc vous êtes challenger vous n'avez
pas gagné ce scrutin vous l'avez dit non
à challenger sa palette vous n'allez pas
que vous l'avez ginger ça veut dire que
vous partez pas en favori
vous avez toute la doc on a gagné avec
lui dans l'it dans l'histoire beaucoup
de challenger font gagner voilà donc on
va gagner ce soir votre mur le molière
vers un beau mot de la fin je suis
content que ça se finisse comme ça roman
de ta dah oui oui on va gagner on va se
donner les moyens à ces les français qui
décideront
et voilà mais il faut vraiment voilà on
ne peut pas continuer avec les mêmes en
aggraver en plus en plus dur en plus
anti social en plus anti économique et
il faut maintenant clairement qu'on
aille vers un vrai changement un mot sur
le président intérimaire du front
national puisque
ne pas inquiéter le poste monsieur jal
qui a été accusé de révisionnisme pour
négation de ce qui s'est passé dans les
camps nazis à leur sort un mot oui alors
vraiment donné qu'il a démenti non mais
là des motifs parce qu'on est vraiment
bien moi je le connais suffisamment
instinct honnête homme inconnu trêve
depuis longtemps et lui octroie des
trucs qui daterait de 26 ans jean
n'importe quoi là dix jours la
présidentielle qu'on n'aurait jamais vu
avant tu as tout ça n'a aucun sens et et
moi je le connais suffisamment eu
suffisamment discuté avec lui pour
savoir que c'est un homme de droit un
honnête homme est un vrai grand patriote
ce qu'on doit respecter
merci merci à tous bon soir
[Musique]